[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
britney spears to speak to a judge about
her conservatorship case
what will the pop icon say about her
13-year long legal battle
and a juror speaks out in the derek
chauvin trial as we learn
what went on in the deliberation room
plus why a north carolina judge is
blocking the release of body cam footage
in the fatal shooting of a man by
deputies and the tennessee man appealing
his life sentence
for the torture and murder of a couple
in their 20s the testimony of eric
bullard's co-defendant attorneys say was
key for a conviction
thomas's testimony was that the
defendant led mr newsom to the vehicle
drove into the train tracks shot him
three times and set his body
on fire law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
pop icon britney spears is set to have
her day in court
terry has more a judge is allowing
spears to speak at her next hearing
about her conservatorship
fans of britney spears are fueling the
free brittany movement
they support her bid to end her 13-year
long conservatorship
she gets a lot of a certain amount of
money per year and she's a worldwide pop
star she should have control of her own
funds
her own money and to me britney spears
is such a sweet soul and such an
intelligent artist
after years of silence the pop star now
says she wants to speak to a judge
herself probate attorney samuel ingram
was appointed to represent spears
he told a los angeles county judge on
tuesday
that spears would like to address the
court on the status of her
conservatorship
anytime there's that amount of money to
be made you have to question the motives
of
everyone close to that person her case
received
new attention after the new york times
documentary framing britney spears
spears recently posted on instagram that
she didn't watch it but quote
cried for two weeks and well i still cry
sometimes
am i okay yes i'm totally fine
i'm extremely happy i have a beautiful
home beautiful children
um i'm taking a break right now because
i'm enjoying myself her father jamie
spears has been conservator
of britney's estate since 2008.
brittany's attorney has said she fears
her father
and wants him removed
last fall the judge appointed a trust as
co-conservator
but that has yet to take effect a
separate hearing on the matter is
scheduled for july
spears is set to appear in court on june
23rd
thanks terry joining us today is former
prosecutor and defense attorney bernardo
villalona
terry what do you think we should expect
uh if britney spears does come to court
and
and speak at her hearing brian you know
it's clear that she is not satisfied
with the way her estate
is being run and i think we're going to
hear her talk about the fact
she's been handling both her personal
affairs and her business affairs we know
for a fact that her children
are well taken care of and we know that
she has been producing music
so there's no question i think she's
going to try to show the court
that she can take care of herself there
hasn't been any mental distress
and it's time that she be able to take
control of her own affairs
how powerful could it be to hear from
spears herself do you think that this
could be more persuasive
than what her lawyers have said on her
behalf
well depending on how she comes off to
the court is going to be a huge
decision-making factor
but i think the court is time for
britney spears to actually speak up for
herself because you have all these
people
serving as the voices for her saying
that she's not confident enough
to handle her own affairs here the judge
is going to be able to access that
himself by hearing her speak out yeah
exactly i think
what she says how she says her body
language all of that is going to be on
display and that's what the judge is
probably going to make
their decision on it's going to be
interesting it's also going to be
interesting to see how this plays out
for the free brittany movement
when her fans see her as well now to the
derek shoven trial
the first juror who deliberated speaking
out telling abc news they reached their
guilty
verdicts in about four hours
um yeah so for me um i'll say i'll say
two
i'm for sure donna williams just you
know just how he spoke about everything
and dr tobin i think once dr tobin
got on the stand and the way he spoke
and the details that he gave
and the way he gave the details um
i thought that really solidified the
prosecution's case
derek chovan not taking the stand did
that have an impact
not hearing from him the former officer
yeah um definitely it did um
when we were in the deliberation room
you know a few people wondered like they
wanted to actually hear from them
they were curious on um you know just
what his thoughts might have been
throughout um you know it probably
probably was to his detriment that he
didn't take the same because people were
curious on what his thoughts were
throughout
the entire incident
bernardo and terry you both covered the
chauvin trial i'm curious about your
reactions
to what juror brandon mitchell said and
if you think especially on that issue
of whether or not derek showman
testified if you see any appellate
issues
terry your thoughts well you know
overall
as far as the interview i liked what he
had to say he talked about the family he
gave his condolences
he said it's important to make sure that
you
show up to have a voice and i thought
that was important
as far as the appeal is concerned it did
bother me a little bit that he talked
about the fact that not getting on the
stand
might have worked to chauvin's detriment
we know that there's a jury charge
that says you cannot use that against
him the question is
whether or not that will be jury
misconduct i don't think
it will be but it did concern me that he
verbalized that
bernardo what do you think so i am
concerned about that last part
of his statement so for them to comment
on the lack of derek shoving
having to testify and that that possibly
played a role
in their deliberations can be an
appellate issue for the defense
because as you know the defendant is not
required to testify at trial and they're
not supposed
to hold it against him if he does not
testify
yeah it's going to be curious from what
i understood uh the gentleman said that
they were curious as to what he would
have said
thought it might have been to his
detriment not to testify
it sounds like he got close to and tara
i'm curious to follow up
sounds like he got close to holding not
testifying against him but not
quite there terry what do you think
about that
i agree with you brian i don't think
it's quite there i mean i think the
other
issues like the legal error you know the
failure of the judge to change venue or
sequester of the jury i think those
appellate issues
might be stronger than the jury you know
quote unquote misconduct
i don't think he got to the point of
saying that that issue would have been
misconduct
uh really quickly bernard would you
expect a lot of appeals in this case
absolutely from the very beginning all
the way to the end because eric nelson
did do a great job in terms of
preserving the record preserving his
objections
for appeal all right we'll see how that
plays out still ahead on law and crime
daily a cold case from 1974
solved after 15 years of questioning the
so-called torso killer
plus why a judge is delaying the release
of law enforcement video
in the fatal shooting of andrew brown jr
when his family will get the video
and will it be made to public next
welcome back let's check in on some of
the top legal stories making headlines
of the law and crime network
a 43 year old nypd officer was struck
and killed by a drunk driver
on the long island expressway officer
anastasio sacos
was investigating an accident in queens
when he was struck by a volkswagen
the nypd later identified 32 year old
jessica bouvet
as the driver who killed the 14 year old
veteran of the force during his final
moments the officer rescued two people
from the earlier crash
sacos leaves behind his wife a
six-year-old daughter and three-year-old
son
and out of new jersey the so-called
torso killer has pled guilty to another
set of murders
richard cottenham admitted to the 1974
deaths of a 17-year-old mary ann pryor
and 16-year-old lorianne kelly
conningham was already serving a life
sentence on five
other murders from the 1960s 74 year old
conham is known as a torso killer for
the way he dismembered his victims
after their deaths singer-songwriter
trey songz will not face charges after
an altercation with the police
the r b artist was arrested at the afc
championship game
for not following coronavirus protocols
as well as other rules at the stadium
trey songz whose legal name is tremaine
alden neverson spent the night in jail
prosecutors say there's insufficient
evidence to bring charges trey song's
representatives
declined to comment on the event
now to north carolina where a judge is
delaying the release of sheriff's office
of video showing the fatal shooting
of andrew brown jr brown was killed last
week by deputies serving him
with an arrest warrant an independent
autopsy commissioned by his family
reportedly shows he was shot five times
with a fatal wound to the base of his
neck
his family and attorney was able to view
a redacted portion
of body cam footage on monday but north
carolina law prohibits law enforcement
from releasing the video without a
judge's order
on wednesday news organizations argue
the five body cam videos and one dash
cam video
should be made public county judge
jeffrey foster said at the hearing quote
the release at this time would create a
serious threat to the fair
impartial and orderly administration of
justice
he ordered the video not be released for
at least 30 days the family would get a
redacted copy in 10 days
in this newly released surveillance
video by elizabeth city deputies
are seen arriving outside brown's home
they piled into the back of a pickup
truck
and turned into his driveway
back with us as criminal defense
attorney bernardo villalona and terry
austin
bernarda a delay in the release of six
videos for 30 days is the judge merely
punting the issue
or does this delay make sense so it does
make sense brian you got to think when
it comes to doing investigations
what the judge doesn't want to see
happen or any prosecutor's office wants
to see happen
that the release of the video footage
taints and makes the
investigation more biased so by not
releasing the video then
they can do an investigation without
having the officers haven't spoken to
each other tried to come up with a plan
as to what they're going to say actually
happen so it does make sense in that
sense that it's not released to the
public
however it will be released to the
family actually to the sun
within 10 to 15 days now terry to that
point the family would be able to view
the video
should we expect them to release the
whole video then
my understanding brian is that they're
going to be able to
view the video it will be disclosed to
them i don't think it will be
turned over to them so they would not be
in a position where they would be able
to release it
the judge has said that it can be viewed
in 10 days that the
police face will be blurred the officers
faces will be blurred
and he apparently will review the video
to determine whether or not
certain portions should be cut out like
the conversations between the police
officers
and their supervisors if you recall that
was done in the derek chovin trial
then in 30 to 45 days we will
perhaps see the release of the video
to the public so it's not a question of
question of if
rather of when i guess that's what we'll
have to wait and see
30 to 45 days unless there's going to be
further arguments that it should be
pushed back
thank you both coming up on law and
crime daily convicted for the torture
rape and murder of a tennessee couple
one defendant is now seeking an appeal
but first the shocking reunion during
her first appearance in florida
the judge the inmate and their reaction
after the break
as a public defender i know firsthand
you never know
who you might see in a bond court and
lawn crying founder and host of the a
e series court camp dan abrams explains
sometimes
even the judge can be caught off guard
stand up and raise your right hand to be
sworn please please stand up
next we head over to the miami dade
court in miami florida
the one sleeping there you can wake up
too in the back row
judge mindy glazers overseeing bond here
thank you
i have a few announcements i'm going to
appoint the public defender to represent
all defendants unless you tell me you
have money to pay for a private lawyer
or
if you are hiring a private lawyer and
one is here also please let me know if
you have served in the united states
military or any of the reserves
good morning good morning
over the next few hours she'll see
dozens of defendants
you were arrested for second-degree
murder as they step
in i'm in the military your honor you
are and quickly step out
hi mr booth how are you how you doing
man
okay man 49 year old arthur booth is a
career criminal
charged with burglary grand theft
fleeing and resisting arrest
you have actually three arrest
affidavits reckless driving
damage to property leaving the scene of
a crash with serious injury
with no serious injury i'm sorry no
serious injury
okay after questioning
judge glazer explains the terms of his
bond
the bond on count one is seventy five
hundred
but the judge notices something familiar
about this defendant
okay mr booth i have a question for you
did you go to nautilus from middle
school oh my goodness
oh my goodness i'm sorry to see you
there i always wondered what happened to
you sir
oh my goodness this is the nicest kid
in middle school oh my goodness he was
the best kid in middle school i used to
play football with him
and all the kids and look what happened
[Music]
the surprise reunion between the two
former middle school classmates
is almost too much for booth to handle
oh my goodness
once a promising student booth fell into
drug and gambling addictions
that led him into a life of petty crime
resulting in multiple stays in prison
oh my goodness
[Applause]
[Music]
good luck to you sir i hope you were
able to
come out of this okay and just lead a
lawful life
the reunion somberly concludes as glazer
sits bail at 43
000
oh my goodness
booth is sent to prison for 10 months
and then released into a drug treatment
program
corcam airs wednesdays on the a e
network
when we come back convicted killer eric
boyd is seeking an appeal
the fifth defendant guilty for the
murders of a tennessee couple in their
20s
his appeal on the other side of this
[Music]
break
welcome back a tennessee man convicted
for the 2007
kidnappings rapes and murders of a young
couple is seeking an appeal
eric boyd was sentenced to spend the
rest of his life in prison
but his attorney says he was wrongfully
accused
the way how she was positioned and the
way how she was
tied to me was telling that
that she was alive and suffocated in the
trash can the death of 21 year old
shannon christian was long and torturous
the medical examiner says christian was
beaten and raped then trapped inside a
trash can
her boyfriend 23-year-old christopher
newsom was also raped before he was shot
three times in his head then
lit on fire the fire now is superimposed
on everything on all the gunshot wounds
and also if
one is alive during fire then the
inhaled
and suit and and and all the fumes from
the fire are going to be deposited
on the airway and there was none of that
the couple was heading out on a date on
january 6
2007 when they were carjacked in front
of their apartment
four people were arrested and charged
with their kidnappings rapes
and murders a fifth eric boyd was
convicted of carjacking
but in 2018 boyd was indicted on 36
charges
including murder after co-defendant
george thomas agreed
to testify against him prosecutors
offered thomas a reduced sentence
from life in prison to 50 years when you
saw the
three flashes who did you see pulling mr
newsome
mr ward and where did he pull this into
directly before me and to the
back of the building what happened after
he uh pulled mr newsome to that location
they came back and grabbed the can of
gas
who did that mr boyd a jury found
47-year-old
eric boyd guilty on all counts and he
was given two life sentences
now boyd is appealing saying thomas's
testimony is uncorroborated
and that the jury pool was tainted due
to media coverage
it is our position that the
evidence is insufficient because mr
thomas was
a co-defendant he was an accomplice and
the well-known rule is that you cannot
convict
a person based solely upon the
uncorroborated testimony of a of a
co-defendant or an accomplice
but prosecutors say the medical evidence
and testimony of other witnesses
corroborates thomas story ms mathis's
testimony
from federal court that she loaned the
defendant her wife tonya
weakened the offenses corroborated
thomas testimony
and xavier jenkins testimony that he saw
mathis's pontiac but she identified in a
photographic lineup
parked behind miss christian's
forerunner at the residence
on the night of the defense also
corroborated george thomas's testimony
let's bring in bernard and terry one
last time to discuss bernard the
prosecutor who
actually graduated from law school with
me laid out uh
why the testament was corroborated by
the co-defendant was that persuasive to
you
yes it was definitely persuasive you
know that when it comes to putting up
a person that is a co-defendant someone
else who played a part in the crime
itself
that the court and jurors look down upon
this type of testimony that's why it's
so important
that there's corroborating factors
corroborating evidence to actually
corroborate
what this person is saying and there was
more than enough corroborating factors
such as the entire testimony of the
medical examiner
as well as the other ladies that also
took part in this incident
now terry i noticed that the judges had
few questions for the prosecutor
and the defense who said they wanted
five minutes for rebuttal
actually gave it up at the end is that a
sign that we should be seeing one side
might be winning this appeal over the
other
no question about that brian you never
want to give up an
opportunity to argue on behalf of your
client i think
clearly in this case the defense was
thinking to himself that he had a losing
argument you heard him there talk about
it was insufficient evidence because the
co-defendant was
the only cooperating evidence and
bernard mentioned no that wasn't the
only evidence and in fact the judge
asked him even if it had been that would
have been okay the case law supports
that
and in fact we didn't even hear a
response
from the defense attorney at that point
he said to himself
well okay judge yeah i guess maybe
you're right so he
clearly was either not arguing well
on behalf of his client or he just you
know didn't do his research but
clearly giving up that rebuttal argument
he
gave up and basically i think didn't do
a great job arguing on behalf of his
client
now bernardo one issue came up that's
interesting it's very similar to new
york the exhaustion rule
when it comes to picking a jury that
seems to be an issue here because the
defense had more preamps to kind of get
out some of the jurors could that be an
issue that
hurts the defense here no i don't think
it's an issue that's going to hurt the
defense because in the end the court is
going to determine based on looking at
all the facts and all the evidence that
was presented in the case
was it harmless error was that an error
that could have changed the outcome
of the case all right thank you both and
thank you for joining us here we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you